c'est un début d'année 2021 mouvementée
pour le gouvernement accusé d'être trop
lents dans la stratégie de vaccination
et je ne le ferai pas davantage pour de
mauvaises raisons
une lenteur injustifiée s'installer dans
vos commentaires
il souligné les couacs précédent de la
crise sanitaire et vous vous demandez
comment l'état peut rattraper ce retard
alors à quoi est due cette lenteur on y
répondent en fait lui tout d'abord
regardons où en sont nos voisins
européens le royaume uni qui a commencé
les vaccinations quasiment trois
semaines avant nous injecter plus de
neuf cent quarante quatre mille doses au
27 décembre
l'allemagne elle 316 mille l'italie 180
2000 le portugal 32000 et la france 7
milles alors pourquoi un tel écart
c'est d'abord un choix stratégique de
l'état qui souhaitait installer la
confiance envers le vaccin dans la
population avec 4 français sur 10 qui
souhaitent se faire vacciner
la france est l'un des pays le plus
défiants du monde je pense pas que c'est
un problème logistique parce qu'en tout
cas on avait on a les doses de vaccin
selon le ministère de la santé on a reçu
60 milles 12 le 26 décembre et puis
ensuite cinq cent mille doses le 29
décembre ce qui fait une capacité à
vacciner environ entre deux cent mille
deux cent cinquante mille personnes
uniquement sans descendre la démarche à
suivre pour se faire vacciner est
également jugée trop lourde par certains
qui souligne la rigidité de l'état les
seules personnes qui pouvaient se faire
vacciner étaient les résidents des ehpad
et pour qu'elles se fassent vacciner
il faut d'abord en a rendez vous chez un
médecin pour recueillir le consentement
puis attendre au moins 5 jours avant la
vaccination pour le défilé du 14 juillet
pour la parade
ça va bien mais lorsque la mitraille se
met d'art prendre
et que l'on n'est plus du tout dans la
parole mais dans ce combat seul canada
il faut adapter la stratégie à la
réalité de l'évolution de la situation
en réponse aux critiques l'état a décidé
de changer de stratégie
selon désormais amplifié accélérer et
simplifier notre stratégie nationale les
soignants pompiers et aides à domicile
de plus de 50 ans peuvent désormais se
faire vacciner
autre changement les plus de 75 ans qui
vivent à domicile pourront se faire
vacciner dès la fin janvier et pour tous
les français qui le souhaitent
il sera possible de se préinscrire et
prendre des rendez vous
premier objectif pour le gouvernement
vacciner un million de personnes jusqu'à
la fin février
il a même revu ses ambitions à la hausse
avec 26 millions de vaccinés d'ici l'été
contre 15 millions à l'origine si encore
une fois les laboratoires livre les
quantités de vaccin pour lesquels ils se
sont engagés et si tous les vaccins sont
efficaces et accepté par l'union
européenne on pourra vacciner 26
millions de personnes en prenant en
compte les deux doses et en prenant en
compte la perte pour vacciner les
soignants dans les hôpitaux et les
médecins généralistes peuvent être
mobilisés mais pas seulement information
m'a contacté et m'a dit on à 20000
pharmacies les pharmacies vaccine déjà
le contre la grippe on a vacciné
plusieurs millions de personnes en une
semaine contre la grippe à l'automne
dernier en octobre je crois qu'on a on a
vacciné 8 millions de personnes en une
semaine les autorités sanitaires doivent
aussi faire face à des défis logistiques
comme pour le vaccin arn messagers de
pfizer qui doit être conservé à moins 80
degrés il faut donc garantir la chaîne
du froid que ce soit pour le transport
ou le stockage mais aussi limiter les
pertes de vaccins un flacon de vaccin
permet de vacciner cinq personnes
alors on n'a pas forcément sous la main
cinq personnes à vacciner donc si on
n'avait pas raison que quatre personnes
à vacciner est bien une des cinq doses
et malheureusement perdu donc
évidemment les autorités vont essayer de
gaspiller le moins possible de doses
pour essayer d'avoir le vacciner un
maximum de monde où tu continueras quand
même 20 à 30 % de pertes
sinon la logistique in gérable d'autant
plus qu'avec le moderne à la contrainte
de tas de température sera moindre
la conservation se fait à moins 20
degrés j'ai encore plus courants
naturellement que le moins 80 degrés
pour les scientifiques vacciner est
d'autant plus urgent que le variant
angles est beaucoup plus contagieux
désormais sur le territoire plus il y a
deux virus qui circule plus il ya de
milliards de milliards de virus circule
plus évidemment il y a deux mutations et
plus par conséquent le riche qu'une de
ces mutations confère un avantage
sélectif rendant un virus plus contagion
et par conséquent en amenant à prendre
le pas sur les autres est grand pour
l'heure l'europe après du retard sur
certaines nations étrangères l'agencé
européenne du médicament demande des
informations scientifiques
supplémentaires pour autoriser celui
d'astrazeneca
[Musique]